Salut Lê, j'ai une question pour toi
Tu es un expert en IA, non?
Quand y aura-t-il des IA de niveau humain?
Salut Jade, d'habitude mes vidéos sont en français.
Je ne parle pas français
OK...
Vu que t'es une superbe YouTubeuse scientifique, je vais faire une exception
Je vais parler en anglais
Même si ça veut dire que tous mes viewers vont moquer mon accent français.
Merci Lê. Et donc ?
Qu'en penses-tu? Une IA de niveau humain est-elle possible?
Les IA peuvent-elles nous surpasser à toute tâche à moindre coût ?
Et si c'est le cas. Quand ?
Ce sont des questions fascinantes
Et si c'est tentant d'avoir une opinion tranchée
mais prenez note d'abord que prédire le futur est très dur
Surtout vu la complexité du monde moderne
Et la vitesse à laquelle il évolue
En particulier, mon grand conseil serait : n'écoutez votre intuition !
Et n'écoutez pas mon intuition non plus!
OK... Mais ça reste une question importante.
Une IA de niveau humain changerait tant de choses !
Comment peut-on construire une opinion informée?
Et bien, même si aucun expert n'est fiable,
Il arrive souvent que
l'avis d'une communauté d'experts donne des réponses plus fiables
Oui et j'ai trouvé cet article
qui dit que les experts en IA ne pensent pas
que l'IA de niveau humain soit une menace pour l'humanité
Attends... T'as vu le follow-up?
Regarde en bas
oui c'est bizarre !
L'article en lien dit l'exact opposé !
Que se passe-t-il ?
il y a des désaccords entre experts
et même des désaccords
sur ce que sont les accords entre experts
C'est le bordel !
et malheureusement les experts en IA n'aident pas
ils préfèrent souvent présenter leur vision du futur de l'IA
ainsi que leur vision du consensus entre experts
mais il y a aussi une cause plus profonde et subtile
du désaccord entre les deux articles
Tu vois ce à quoi je fais référence ?
Ça a à voir avec comment penser les risques
je crois que je vois ce que tu veux dire
Le 1e article parle d'un sondage où on demande aux experts quand il y aura une IA de niveau humain
alors que le 2nd article parle de probabilités pour une date donnée
et il est possible que
presque tous les experts pensent qu'il n'y aura pas d'IA de niveau humain en 2050
tout en pensant qu'il y a 10% de chances qu'il y ait une IA de niveau humain en 2020.
Exactement !
Et quand on parle de risques, il est crucial de parler de façon probabiliste.
Typiquement, une centrale nucléaire qui ne va probablement pas exploser
n'est pas nécessairement une central nucléaire rassurante
Clairement !!
Même si la probabilité d'explosion est de 1%
je dirais qu'il faut quand même s'en préoccuper
et il faudrait se préparer au pire
et en particulier, il ne faudrait pas donner trop d'importances à des sondages qui demandent uniquement les scénarios les plus probables
Et par chance, en 2015, les experts en IA
ont été sondés avec des questions probabilistes
Et parmi 1364, 352 ont accepté de répondre
Tu devrais aller voir ça, Jade !
Wow ! Ce sondage demande aux experts de dessiner un graphe
pour chaque date, il demande la probabilité
d'une IA de niveau humain avant cette date
Et voici à quoi ressemblent les courbes de différents experts (en fin)
Et en rouge, on a là un aggrégat des avis des experts
Une chose importante à observer est à quel point les experts sont en désaccord
Du coup, aucun expert ne peut être représentatif de l'ensemble des experts
En particulier, il y a un énorme biais de sélection
à chaque fois qu'on donne de l'importance à un expert donné
Regardons donc l'aggrégat des experts
Selon lui, il y a 50% de chances pour une IA de niveau humain avant 2061
Donc on a le temps de voir venir
selon les experts, l'IA de niveau humain dans plusieurs décennies est le scénario le plus probable
mais en termes de risques, on devrait aussi s'intéresser aux scénarios moins probables
ils disent aussi qu'il y a 10% de chances d'une IA de niveau humain avant 2025 !
Lê, c'est très bientôt !
Oui ! Et 10%, c'est tout sauf négligeable !
Encore une fois, une centrale nucléaire avec 10% de chances d'exploser
ne devrait clairement pas être construite !
Et pourtant, une IA de niveau humain pourrait être encore plus explosive !
Comme on en a longuement parlé sur ma chaîne
et comme Robert Miles le fait sur la sienne
l'IA de niveau humain pose des risques existentiels pour l'humanité
À moins d'investir massivement dans la sécurité des IA
l'IA de niveau humain pourrait bien détruire l'humanité
Ou du moins, il y a un argumentaire solide par Nick Bostrom dans son livre "Superintelligence"
qu'il faut voir la destruction de l'humanité comme le scénario par défaut qui fait suite à une IA de niveau humain
OK... Mais 10% c'est l'avis des experts.
Peut-on leur faire confiance ?
les experts ne se sont-ils pas trompé par le passé ?
Oui. Clairement.
Par exemple, Marvin Minsky pensait que l'IA de niveau humain serait là dès les années 1970.
il avait surestimé la vitesse du progrès
mais les erreurs de prédiction n'ont pas toujours été causées par une surestimation du progrès
En fait, ces derniers temps, il semble que l'inverse soit davantage vrai
Par exemple, dans le sondage de 2015,
les experts ont prédit qu'il faudrait 12 ans pour qu'une IA surpasse les humains au Go
mais AlphaGo battit Lee Sedol quelques mois plus tard
À supposer qu'ils se trompent tout autant pour l'IA de niveau humain
ceci suggère qu'on ne peut pas exclure la possibilité
qu'une IA atteigne le niveau humain d'ici quelques années
Je vois...
le manque de fiabilité des experts doit être vu comme un ajout d'incertitude
si la distribution des prédictions des experts est une courbe en cloche alors cette incertitude additionnelle devrait écraser la courbe
mais regardez !
ça veut dire que la probabilité des cas extrêmes devrait augmenter
oui, parce que les experts sont souvent en excès de confiance
on devrait être d'autant plus préoccupé
par la possibilité d'IA de niveau humain dans un futur proche.
Au lieu de 10% pour 2025
on pourrait considérer 10% pour 2022.
OK... Mais tout ça est très dur à imaginer
L'IA n'aurait-elle pas besoin d'une "vraie" intelligence ou conscience ?
Et quid de la consommation d'énergie ?
Les machines peuvent-elles faire aussi bien que le cerveau humain ?
Il y a clairement d'énormes obstacles pour atteindre l'IA de niveau humain
mais la recherche avance à un rythme impressionnant
à la fois en hardware et en software
en termes de hardware
la loi de Koomey suggère que le coût énergétique d'un calcul décroît exponentiellement vite
et est divisé par 2 tous les 18 mois
Et des structures de stockage et de calcul parallélisés, voire décentralisés,
pourrait permettre à cette tendance de se poursuivre
Et quid du software ? A-t-on besoin d'une énorme innovation ?
Probablement... C'est dur à dire.
mais pour comprendre les défis software
c'est pas mal de revenir à l'article de Turing de 1950
il y suggère qu'une grande portion de la complexité du cerveau humain
est critique pour atteindre l'intelligence humaine
mais le cerveau humain a environ 10^15 synapses
si 1% d'entre eux sont indispensables pour l'intelligence de niveau humain
ça suggère qu'une IA de niveau humain devra faire au moins 1 TeraOctets
aujourd'hui, les grandes IA font souvent quelques Gigaoctets
et les plus grandes se rapprochent du Teraoctet
Ceci suggère qu'en termes de complexité
on pourrait bientôt atteindre ce qui est nécessaire pour l'intelligence de niveau humain
Ça reste dur d'imaginer que ceci suffise pour atteindre l'IA de niveau humain
n'a-t-on pas besoin d'entraîner ces IA?
oui. Mais beaucoup des données nécessaires
sont possiblement déjà disponibles !
pour atteindre le niveau humain, une grande IA bien conçue
pourrait lire Wikipedia encore et encore, et regarder le YouTube scientifique
c'est une chose d'être exposé à ces données
mais l'IA pourra-t-elle apprendre des données ?
ceci pourra-t-il conduire à une "vraie" intelligence?
encore une fois, c'est dur à dire
mais j'insiste dessus : c'est dur à dire
beaucoup semblent penser que, parce que l'IA ne fait que des opérations mécaniques,
elles ne peuvent pas atteindre le niveau humain
mais le truc, c'est que de longs calculs mécaniques sont plein de surprises !
ils conduisent à des résultats que nous autres humains ne pouvons pas prédire !
Pas parce que les calculs sont compliqués.
En fait chaque calcul est ultra simpliste
mais les IA font un très grand nombre de ces calculs
voilà une chose que nos cerveaux ne peuvent pas faire
et c'est pour ça que nos cerveaux ne peuvent pas prédire le résultat des calculs des IA
ce qui veut dire que ces calculs donneront des résultats qui vont nous surprendre
Alan Turing l'a parfaitement expliqué
L'idée que les machines ne peuvent pas donné lieu à des surprises est due, je pense
à un sophisme fallacieux auxquels les philosophes et mathématiciens ont particulièrement sujets.
C'est l'hypothèse selon laquelle
dès qu'un fait est présenté à un esprit
toutes les conséquences de ce fait sautent simultanément à l'esprit
c'est une hypothèse très utile dans bien des cas
mais on oublie trop vite qu'elle est fausse
Une conséquence naturelle de cela est que
on suppose alors qu'il n'y a pas de vertu
dans le simple calcul des conséquences de données et de principes généraux
Exactement!
Et donc on ne devrait pas être en excès de confiance concernant ce qu'on pense qu'une IA peut faire
Leurs longs calculs vont probablement nous surprendre
En fait, si vous avez suivi l'actualité de l'IA
vous avez sans doute été surpris
par les images photoréalistes de NVIDIA, les sous-titres automatiques de YouTube
et les appels téléphoniques de Google Duplex
Bonjour
Bonjour, je voudrais réserver une table pour mercredi 7
pour 7 personnes ?
C'est pour 4 personnes
4 personnes ? Quand ?
Aujourd'hui ? Ce soir ?
Mercredi prochain à 18h
En fait, les réservations sont pour 5 personnes ou plus.
Pour 4 personnes, pas de réservation
Quelle est l'attente?
Quand? Demain ? Le week-end?
Pour mercredi prochain, le 7.
Il n'y a pas trop de monde. Vous pouvez venir, ok?
Oh ! Compris ! Merci !
C'était un vrai appel !
Bien souvent, les appels ne vont pas comme prévu
mais notre IA comprend le contexte, les nuances
et gère l'interaction avec grâce !
Oui ! Et donc, il faut s'attendre à d'autres avancées surprenantes en IA
peut-être jusqu'à leur donner des facultés de raisonnement de niveau humain
Et vu tout ce qu'on a vu, je dirais qu'il y a un argumentaire solide
pour dire qu'une IA de niveau humain avant 2025, ça a une probabilité supérieure à 1%
Et à y réfléchir, 1%, c'est énorme !
surtout sachant à quel point ce serait disruptif !
C'est pour ça que je prétendrais que la menace d'une IA de niveau humain devrait vraiment être prise au sérieuse !
Et investir massivement en sécurité des IA